[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY ZMOLEK: Let me start
with a quick survey.
How many of you have
applications that require
enterprise end users to log in?
Quite a few?
How many of you
are using WebView
to help accomplish that?
All right, this session
is for you especially.
I'm Andy Zmolek.
I am ecosystem cat herder
on the Android team.
I work with a lot
of different Android
for Work ecosystem partners.
And I also work very closely
with the Identity team
at Google.
And so I'm going to let William
introduce himself and kick this
off.
WILLIAM DENNISS: Hi, everyone.
So I'm William Denniss, product
manager on the Identity team.
And one of the goals
of Identity at Google
is to build a kind
of consistent model
of the user and their
devices, and use that
so that we don't have to
reauthenticate them quite as
frequently.
You may notice that the Google
session on your Android device
has an incredibly
long lived session.
And you almost never have
to reauthenticate to Google
if you need to sign into
something like, say, Stack
Overflow.
And that's a result
of the efforts
that the Identity team
have been working on.
And so with the
consumer use cases
fairly well under control, we're
not turning a bit of attention
to the enterprise
use cases to see
what we can do to improve
the user experience there.
So the typical enterprise
user will see a login screen
like these several times,
or fairly frequently.
And they'll need to sign in with
the same credentials, typically
their corporate credentials,
into each of those apps.
And quite often
these apps are using
WebView as a way to extract
the difficulty of integrating
with a lot of different IDPs.
ANDY ZMOLEK: Identity
providers for those of you
that aren't Identity guys yet.
WILLIAM DENNISS: Yes, thank you.
So using the WebView,
the user will log in
with their same
corporate credentials,
but they'll be doing
it multiple times.
And what I don't like about that
is that to me it doesn't really
provide single sign on, or at
least not the user friendly
definition of single sign
on which I prefer to use,
and that is that the
user only signs in once,
as opposed to the alternative
definition of single sign
in where the user is
signing on multiple times
but using the same credentials.
So certainly that is still
better than what came before.
But I think we can
do better still.
The other problem with
using WebView for all this
is that there's not a great
security model in that the host
app can actually
extract the cookies
or inject JavaScript and do
basically whatever it wants.
And this basically violates the
principle of least privilege
because the host app is getting
a more powerful credential
than what it really needs.
And you may be thinking, well,
that's not a problem for me
because I trust my developers.
They're not going to be
stealing the cookies.
injecting any JavaScript.
And that is certainly
true for a lot of people.
We had these enterprise
contracts and developers
get paid.
And then no ones trying
to do anything bad.
But we've actually
seen in the wild
a few times where an honest
developer has inadvertently
run into problems just by
including a third party SDK.
And the problem here is that
like any of the third party
SDKs that they include could
be doing something bad as well.
And so that trust necessarily
goes to every single SDK
that they're using.
And the other thing is maybe you
do have less trusted developers
and maybe you don't want to
audit every single line of code
in your app.
So this model does
suffer a few security
problems using WebView.
So now Andy's going to talk
about a new feature in Android
that looks like it could be set
to replace WebView as the way
to get people signed in.
ANDY ZMOLEK: And
one of the things
we want to reinforce
throughout this session
is we're not talking
about Google identity
here, although it works
with Google identity.
This has nothing
to do with using
Google Identity in your
SaaS or your SaaS app
or signing on an enterprise
user with a Google identity.
Everything that we're
going to show you
is going to work with standard
OAuth and standard OpenID
Connect.
And we'll get into
more details here.
But what I want to start
with is, what's a custom tab,
and why should you care
about using a custom tab
when you're doing a sign in?
First of all, you'll notice
that what we've got here
is at the very top--
WILLIAM DENNISS: Middle button.
ANDY ZMOLEK: Middle
button, all right.
At the very top, you
have an address bar.
That address bar is locked.
So the user can see
where they're going,
but they can't change
the destination.
The other thing
here is everything
that you see inside here
makes use of what's already
existing in the shared cookie
jar in the Chrome system
browser.
So what you're going
to see is completely
reflected by the content.
You'll see this in
the demos that we do.
The cookie state is something
you can take advantage of.
That's not something you
can do with a WebView.
And then the last and
most important thing
is this is not requiring an
app flip to get to Chrome.
It's an activity that shows up
within the native application.
So there's a particular Android
API even for this that works.
There's a support library,
literally goes all the way back
to Android 1.6.
So let's suppose
that you happen to be
the developer of a alternative,
non-Chrome browser.
Guess what?
You can do exactly
this same capability
and do custom tab for developers
to use and go all the way back
to older versions of Android
and still get this capability.
So there's an example
implementation here.
There's an example client.
And basically this is
everything you need.
Let's say if you're an OEM
and you've got your own web
app that's delivered
as part of your phone,
you can use these to get
the same capabilities.
So Chrome Custom Tabs
came out in Chrome 45.
They're a few versions back now.
You've probably seen
it in applications
where instead of
using WebView, you're
now seeing something
that actually knows
your authentication state
or knows who you are,
when you come in.
In many cases it wasn't done
for authentication purposes,
it was done so the
user experience
was a little bit cleaner.
Now the great thing
about this-- there we go.
Take a look at how much
faster Chrome Custom
Tabs are than either WebView
or the system browser.
Even if you just
wanted to improve
the performance, the rendering
performance of what's
happening, Chrome Custom
Tabs are an awesome solution.
And there's great videos
on there for app developers
that want to use Chrome Custom
Tabs for other things as well.
But the important takeaway
here for our purposes today
is they're fast,
they're secure, and they
go all the way back
to versions of Android
that are-- actually we'll
get into a little bit more.
Basically Jelly Bean and beyond
is supported specifically
by the version of
Chrome, Chrome 45,
that we'll be making use of.
WILLIAM DENNISS: Cool.
So let's talk about how we
can use this new Android
feature to improve the
authentication experience
for our users.
And you'll probably
notice that I've
put an iOS screen here as well.
So everything I'm about
to talk about actually
works on both Android
and iOS, although we'll
be mostly showing the
Android demos in this talk.
But that's good news if
you're a developer because one
of the hardest things
about auth if you're
dealing with a lot of
different authorization service
or a lot of different
identity providers,
you don't really want
have to convince everybody
to make a change.
And so the good thing
here is that regardless
of what platform
your apps are on,
you can use the same pattern.
You won't have to kind of go
to the same identity providers
twice.
So let me run a quick
video of what the end user
experience will look like.
OK, so for this
example app, the user
is signing in using PingFederate
as their authentication server.
And the app has just launched a
Chrome Custom Tab with an OAuth
2 authorization request.
And in this case the user
does need to reauthenticate.
But you will notice that the
user name was already there,
probably from a
previous authentication.
Once the user
authenticates, they
can then approve the request.
And the OAuth authorization
code is returned
to the app via an Intent.
The app can exchange
that for the access token
and make an API call.
All right, so we just going
to clear out the data here
of the app to simulate the
user using a second app
and take a look at what that
experience is going to be.
So the second time the user
logs into a different app,
you'll notice that they're
already authenticated.
And that's due to the shared
cookie state with Chrome.
So it's a simple tap, no
password, no reauthentication.
They can get back in.
And we can make that API call.
So that was PingFederate
as an authorization server.
Now let's try Google.
Basically it's
the same approach.
The user's already
signed in thanks
to the account on
the Android device.
We can approve the request,
get the authorization code,
exchange that for an access
token, and make an API call.
All right, what about something
a little bit more complicated?
So here we're going to
open PingFederate again,
but this time we're
going to actually chain
the authorization and use
a different authentication
provider, in this case Google.
So PingFed has actually
redirected to Google
to do the authentication,
which then responds.
The user then approves the
request, and they're done.
For completeness,
let's run this again,
cleaning out the app data.
So again, we open the
OAuth 2 authorization
request to PingFed, but because
we have the saved cookie state,
it knew it was
already using Google,
so it's redirected
straight away.
User's accepted the
request, and we're good.
All right, so what
just happened?
Basically the first time
the user needs to log in,
they'll get the same login
screen that they used to.
And they'll sign in once.
But then on subsequent apps
that the user installs,
they don't need to
repeat that sign on.
And if you're dealing with a
reauthentication environment,
something where you have
a short lived session.
Maybe it's a day.
Hopefully it's longer.
But the good news there
is that even in that case,
the user is still only
reauthenticating once.
They don't have to keep
doing that for every app
that they use.
And those more complex chain
authed scenarios work as well.
And we see these
quite a lot where
you have various different
bits of middleware all
doing their own thing.
As far as the app is
concerned, all it really knows
is that it's talking OAuth 2.
It's opening a request and
it's waiting for an Intent.
And everything else that
happens in the middle
is actually just handled
by the browser in Chrome.
The sky's the limit on what
you can do in the middle there.
You can use second factor or you
can redirect anyway you want.
And this pattern works with
any authorization server
that supports native apps.
And I'll get a little
bit more detail
about what that actually means
in the next couple slides.
Let's look at some
sequence diagrams.
So this is the sequence
diagram for a typical SaaS app.
And you'll see that an
optional step here, you
can use the tools
that others have
been talking about today to
push a manage configuration
to the SaaS app.
And you can provide things
like the tenant hint
or the user hint in
that configuration.
ANDY ZMOLEK: We should
point out that's optional.
WILLIAM DENNISS: Yes.
And the SaaS app then
does an OAuth request
to the SaaS backend.
From that point on, it's
effectively a black box
as far as the app
developer is concerned.
And the SaaS backend
will then typically
redirect to an enterprise
authorization server,
perform whatever it needs to do,
before responding with an OAuth
response.
The IT app case
is fairly similar,
just a little bit simpler,
because the It app only
has to talk to one IDP,
one identity provider.
It can just load the
OAuth request directly
to its authorization server.
And again you have
that same black box.
ANDY ZMOLEK: And typically
the developer in this case
will be hard coding the identity
provider within their app,
because there's only one.
In the SaaS case,
the SaaS developer
has got to deal with
an arbitrary number.
And those specific
identity providers
won't even be known
to the app beforehand.
But the SaaS service
backend will know.
WILLIAM DENNISS: Right.
And so I've talked about
this black box of like,
the app doesn't
really know what's
happening in that authorization
happening in the Chrome Custom
Tab.
And one of the cool things
is that because it's
a real browser, you get every
feature that the real browser
has, such as mutual TLS.
So if you're an EMM, you
can basically push that TLS
certificate to the browser.
And the app can
take advantage of it
without the certificate
actually needing
to be pushed to the app.
And I think that's a really big
advantage because previously
you may have to push that
certificate to every single one
of the apps.
And the apps will have
to understand it as well.
And if that's only like
one or two customers,
it can be a lot of work
and hard to justify.
But this way because
it is a black box
as far as the app
is concerned, you
can build in all these
additional authentication
things in that black box.
And we actually discovered
some pretty cool yesterday,
which is that FIDO-- if
you're heard of FIDO,
the U2F standard, can also
work inside this custom tab
black box as well.
So really there are a lot
of cool things you can do.
ANDY ZMOLEK: Before we
switch, I want to point out,
if it's an end
device, the end user
doesn't even have to
deal with this dialogue
to be able to get that
certificate bound up within it.
WILLIAM DENNISS: Good point.
Thank you.
Thanks for a good
screenshot though I guess.
All right, so in terms of
support, as Andy mentioned,
the custom tab itself is
available I think back
to Android 1.6.
But Chrome shipped
that in Chrome 45,
which is present on
about 95% of devices.
And the story for iOS
is pretty good as well.
The important to note is
that even though there
is a small percentage of users
that may not get the custom
tab, there is a
universal fallback, which
is that we can simply just open
the browser, the full browser,
with that exact same
authorization request
and wait for the exact
same Intent coming back.
So 100% of users are supported.
It's just that, say,
95% get that sort
of improved experience.
All right, so how do we help
you actually implement this?
Well to start with, we have
a draft best current practice
going through the ITF OAuth
working group right now.
I'm a coauthor of the draft
along with John Bradley, who's
in the audience today.
And this best practice details
how you can, as a relying party
or as an identity provider,
implement these best practices
and do it correctly
and securely.
ANDY ZMOLEK: It's
important to point out,
this has been accepted
by the OAuth working
group as an official
working group item.
So this is not just two
guys writing a draft.
This is actually the OAuth
working group taking this up.
And we'll be publishing
this as a BCP.
WILLIAM DENNISS: Hopefully
we'll get it out sometime
later this year.
And so what are the requirements
for an authorization server?
Well, it's sort of
three main points here.
The first is, don't assume that
the client can keep a secret.
Now this is probably
an assumption
that you're not making if
you're doing any kind of app
authentication today.
So that one's
probably pretty easy.
The second is that you
need to support custom URI
schemes for the OAuth redirect.
Now the OAuth spec
itself actually
just defines the redirect
URI as a URI, which
could use any scheme.
But a lot of people when
they implemented it,
they sort of assumed that it
was an HTTPS redirect scheme.
So in some cases you may need
to do a little bit of work
on the authorization
server just to relax
that requirement a little bit
and allow for any arbitrary
scheme for the redirect.
And finally, something
that we recommend
is that you support PKCE,
which is called the Proof
Key for Code Exchange.
And that just adds a little
bit of extra protection
in this interapp
communication environment
where we're using Intents and
there's a potential for things
to get intercepted.
It's a fairly lightweight
extension to OAuth.
All right, if you're
an app developer,
we have even better new for
you, because the teams at Google
have actually
contributed a reference
library to the OpenID
Foundation, which
we call AppAuth.
And this reference library is
available on Android and iOS.
And it completely implements the
best practice specifications.
So it'll handle the
authorization request.
It'll add in PKCE.
It will do everything correctly.
And one of the real benefits
of actually having our team
provide this code,
particular on Android,
is that we've taken care of some
of the complexities of using
a browser to do
this type of flow.
So for example, we're
going to check the system
to see if the user has-- if
their default browser has
custom tab support.
And if it doesn't, then
we'll look for any browser
that has custom tab support.
And if there are
none, then we're
looking down the list basically
until we find a suitable user
agent to load the request in.
And there is a
production example.
So Google on iOS is a third
party, just like many of you
are a third party on Android.
And so we follow
these best practice
for our own sign in API on iOS.
And I think Facebook is doing
something similar as well.
So if you want to see
some examples of these
actually in production,
there's a couple today.
And let's talk a bit
about the implementation.
ANDY ZMOLEK: We
mentioned earlier
that it's optional to use
managed configuration here.
And let me explain how that's
done and why that's done.
First of all, you're
probably used to,
when you're signing
in to a SaaS app,
putting your email address
in first, sometimes
putting your password
in on the same page.
But you've noticed
that recently,
a lot of SaaS
developers have started
doing what we call tenant
discovery by taking your email
address first before you
provide any password.
So that's how the SaaS
backend, the SaaS app
and the SaaS backend
figure out which
identity provider to go to.
Well the great thing about
managed configuration
is you can, using the EMM, using
the configuration for a given
enterprise customer,
already tell
which backend, which tenant,
which IDP should be hit.
And in many cases,
you're also going
to be able to tell what
the user name should be.
In fact in many cases it's
valuable for the enterprise
to be able to specify the exact
account that should be used.
And the great
thing about this is
when you do that, you can
go right to the password
as the very first screen
that the user sees.
Managed configuration could
even send the password too,
but we don't recommend that.
That's certainly not a very
good security best practice.
But the point is you can make it
so that the only thing the user
has to do after they click on
that app is put their password
in for the very first time.
Every subsequent app that uses
that same identity provider,
the next time that the
user clicks on another app,
it goes straight in.
It's been completely
provisioned.
The user hasn't even
had to put anything in.
So managed
configuration, you start
with the developer
defining in that-- well,
in their manifest what
those app restrictions are.
The admin on the EMM
console figures out
what specific configuration
to send for that app using
managed configuration.
The device policy
controller is the one
that actually sends that down.
Or as you saw with
Play going forward,
you're going to be able
to do that through Play.
And then the app
receives that information
and goes straight to the
information that they need.
So these are the specific APIs.
None of this is
particularly new.
This has been here
since Lollipop.
But you can now use that to
tee up and take full advantage
of AppAuth for single sign in.
WILLIAM DENNISS: All
right, speaking of AppAuth,
let's go through a
brief code example
of how you would actually use
AppAuth in your app today.
So the first thing
that you need to do
is spin up a
configuration object,
supplying the authorization
and the token endpoints.
Or if the identity provider
supports dynamic discovery,
there's a way you do that too.
Next you build
the OAuth request,
specifying what scopes you need.
In this case we're just
looking for the identity
scopes of the user's
profile and email address.
And then finally to
send that request
that you built to Apple, it will
load up the Chrome Custom Tab
or fall back to
the default browser
if Chrome Custom
Tabs isn't ready.
Next, to actually get that OAuth
authorization code coming back
to the app, you need to
listen for the Intent which
is your redirect URI.
And so you'll need to
edit the app manifest
and add a new
Intent filter there
to watch for your
redirect scheme.
And since we're talking
about redirect schemes,
let me talk briefly
about what you should do
to pick a good URI scheme here.
And what we recommend is using a
collision resistant URI scheme,
so something like using
a reverse DNS style.
So something like
com.youcompany.yourapp
would be a good
choice because what
it means that no other app
is going to accidentally pick
that same scheme, at least
not in an honest way.
And you should avoid things
like app or generic words
because there could be
inadvertent collisions.
And you may be thinking,
well, that malicious app could
actually just register
my scheme anyway.
And that is
certainly true, which
is why on the previous
slide I recommended
that the authorization
server should
support that PKCE specification,
which mitigates that problem.
OK, so once you've registered
that Intent in your app's
manifest, then you
receive that Intent.
Then you pass it
on to the library,
which will analyze the URL and
extract out the authorization
code.
At which point you exchange
the authorization code
for a refresh token, access
token, and [INAUDIBLE] token.
And then finally you
can make an API call
with that access token.
And AppAuth also provides
a convenient API here
where you can just
wrap up your API call.
And we'll take care of the
token freshness for you.
So if the access
token is expired,
we will hit the token
endpoint, refresh that token,
and then call your API
call with that fresh token,
or with an error
if an error code.
So that's just took a brief
demo of using AppAuth.
I highly encourage you to
visit the GitHub repository,
download the sample,
and give it a try.
If you have any
questions or comments,
please file an
issue in the GitHub.
The team is very responsive.
We're always looking at those.
And so we'll definitely fix
any problems that you find.
And with that I think we--
ANDY ZMOLEK: I should
mention a couple of things
because we've gone
through so much material.
And what a lot of people
may not recognize,
this is a problem that we've
had with native mobile apps
on all platforms for years.
And it's only recently that
Android's Chrome Custom
Tabs on iOS 9 Safari
View Controller
provided kind of a
roadmap to go do this.
But this reference library
is really what's new.
Does everyone have to use the
reference library as it is?
No.
They can go and they
can fork the GitHub
and make it so that
it works better
with their
authentication scheme.
Is this a Google
identity solution?
No, this works
with any standard.
Really the patterns that
you see with WebSSO apps,
with web browsers
today, we're just
replicating those here
so that they work better
with native apps.
WILLIAM DENNISS: So that demo
that I showed earlier actually
was built with
AppAuth, and as you
saw used PingFederate, which
is a third party enterprise
identity provider.
So, yeah.
Great.
Let's take some questions.
We've got a few minutes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
The name, Chrome Custom Tabs,
I find that a little confusing.
Can you give a little background
about why that's the name
and do you feel it's
descriptive of what it is?
And if not, what
would you call it?
ANDY ZMOLEK: So
there's custom tabs,
which is an Android thing.
Chrome was the
first system browser
to implement custom tabs APIs.
And so when you use
what's in every phone that
is launched with
Google Services on it,
you're guaranteed
to at least have
Chrome Custom Tabs available
to you as a developer.
So Chrome Custom Tabs--
Well let me explain the
concept of custom tabs.
The idea with custom tabs
is you're an app developer.
You want to be able to show
some website, or in many cases,
it's kind of social
use cases where
the idea was, let's
make it easier
for developers to access things
that are in the cookie jar
so that they can have more
context in these social sites.
It turns out that it's also
really good for authentication.
So Custom Tabs is an
improvement on the WebViews
that gives you access
to the cookie jar,
and gives you as a developer
a whole bunch of cool things.
Chrome Custom Tabs is a
Chrome implementation of that.
Like I say, if you're
a browser developer,
you can have your own
custom tabs as well.
WILLIAM DENNISS: I guess
regarding the name-- I don't
know who came up with the name.
I think the idea is
that it's a custom
tab running inside the app.
The app can actually
change the color.
They can put an icon there.
They can put an action button.
So I think we had one slide
there a while back where
Pinterest could put
like a Pin It button.
And so I guess those are
the customization options
that you have.
And perhaps that
explains the name.
When it comes to kind of the
generic pattern in the spec,
I actually refer to as
like an in app browser tab
as like a generic way to refer
to the feature on both iOS
and Android.
ANDY ZMOLEK: I
suppose it's worth
pointing out that
our full session
name is "Using AppAuth for
SSO with Chrome Custom Tabs."
Kind of got shortened
to Chrome Custom Tabs.
But it's AppAuth that we are
specifically promoting here.
WILLIAM DENNISS: And the
pattern behind AppAuth, yeah.
ANDY ZMOLEK: Right,
exactly, the web pattern,
which previously you had
to use a proprietary SDK
from an identity provider
to do anything similar.
AUDIENCE: Maybe we'll
have time for one more.
AUDIENCE: One more?
Well I'll feel bad if I
ask the wrong question.
So out of curiosity, so
what makes custom tab faster
than the standalone
Chrome browser?
Anything you can share?
Why?
WILLIAM DENNISS: Right,
so that's this one here.
My theory is that switching
to the actual browser
just incurs a switching cost.
Like there's this
time to-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Here we go.
Hold on.
AUDIENCE: So yeah,
so Chrome Custom Tabs
have a few features that
allow you to preload the web
page before you switch context.
And that allows you to
have the resources ready.
There's warm up
features essentially.
WILLIAM DENNISS: That's
a really good point.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
and so that's why
you get that faster switching.
WILLIAM DENNISS: That's
a really good point.
Yeah, so the app can basically
warm up that authorization
request, have it ready to go.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to pick
one more small question.
AUDIENCE: Very small question.
So the Google login page
was using a WebView.
And is that why it's going to
switch to using custom tabs?
WILLIAM DENNISS:
So we are looking
at various things like that.
Google is kind of
special on Android
because we're a first party.
So a lot of the things I said
about WebView being problematic
is not actually true if you
control the platform end
to end, because obviously
that you trust yourself.
But we are always
looking at various things
and where we can improve.
[MUSIC PLAYING]